you say you're willing to die on this
hill you taking a lot of heat for this
explain what you are thinking there are
some very very you know militant type
forces in Black lives matter and what I
was issuing was a warning and when you
have the leaders of the black lives
movement who are now talking about you
know if we don't get our demands we're
going to burn it down uh other black
people who are talking about working
with other whites and other uh other
races they're they're being viewed as
sellouts are called
Uncle it starts starts you start to
understand that you are now you know
being controlled you're and I viewed it
as a very very dangerous
self-righteousness that was developing
that you know that that really viewed
themselves as better it was almost a
supremist move Terry Cruz hey black
white people let's all unite together
let's fight the forces of eil and blah
blah blah blah blah but he's kind of the
scary person in the picture